Extrema derecha y Alemania son dos términos que causan auténtico terror cuando van juntos
en la misma frase. De hecho, aunque Ángela Merkel haya vuelto a ganar las elecciones
por un margen bastante aceptable, la victoria ha dejado un sabor agridulce. El hecho de
que Alternativa por Alemania, un partido xenófobo y de ultraderecha, haya quedado como tercera
fuerza en el parlamento, es razón suficiente para quitarle el sueño a la canciller.
“No vamos a dar excusas, está claro que
queríamos un resultado mejor” –Ángela MERKEL
En VisualPolitik teníamos pensado empezar esta semana con un vídeo explicando por qué
Merkel ha ganado las elecciones en Alemania. Sin embargo, hemos pensado que lo mejor era
posponer la publicación del vídeo un día
más para poderos hablar de este otro partido
político; Alternativa por Alemania o, por
sus siglas, la AFD. Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis
pensando… ¡Fonseca! ¿Cómo te puede sorprender que la extrema derecha haya entrado en el
parlamento alemán? A fin de cuentas, en casi todos los países de Europa hay partidos xenófobos
con bastante fuerza. Por otra parte, AFD ya
había cosechado buenos resultados en las
últimas elecciones locales. Sin embargo, casi todas las encuestas apuntaban
a que los alemanes apreciaban la moderación mucho más que los ciudadanos de ningún otro
país. Por ejemplo, en Francia, el 50% de
los votantes se sitúa en el centro. En Alemania,
esta cifra llega, o llegaba, al 76%.
Por otra parte, el país de Ángela Merkel
apenas sufrió la crisis económica. Es más,
su economía pasa por uno de sus mejores momentos.
Los sueldos están subiendo, prácticamente rozan el pleno empleo y las empresas exportan
al mundo entero como si no existiera mañana. Todo esto, por no hablar del pasado de
Así que la pregunta es ¿Quiénes han votado a la extrema derecha alemana? Y lo que es
más importante ¿Qué es y qué propone Alternativa por Alemania? ¿De verdad hablamos de un partido
de extrema derecha o los medios están exagerando? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas. Pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
UN PARTIDO POLÍTICO DIVIDIDO
Es cierto, hoy en día, Alternativa por Alemania es un partido populista cuya principal propuesta
es el rechazo a los refugiados y a los inmigrantes, sobretodo, los que vienen de países musulmanes.
Sin embargo, sus orígenes son totalmente
distintos. Hablamos del año 2013. Por aquel
entonces, todos los medios de comunicación europeos hablaban de la crisis de la deuda
en España, Italia y, sobretodo, Grecia.
Para los que nos conozcáis bien la historia,
os hago un resumen. Antes de la crisis de
2008, los bancos alemanes habían invertido
en dar préstamos a los gobiernos y las empresas del Sur de Europa. Después de la crisis de
2008, esos países no sólo no podían devolver sus deudas sino que, además, necesitaban
pedir aún más dinero prestado para poder
seguir pagando sus gastos corrientes: los
sueldos de los funcionarios, el mantenimiento de los hospitales, las carreteras, etc…
Lógicamente, esa situación era y es insostenible. Así que Ángela Merkel dijo “vale, os vamos
a prestar más dinero… incluso os vamos
a dejar que nos lo devolváis poco a poco.
Pero tenéis que reformar vuestros países”.
Seguro que los que veáis este vídeo desde
España ya sabéis a lo que me refiero. Efectivamente, estoy hablando de la famosa AUSTERIDAD. Es
decir, Alemania, junto a otros países del
Norte de Europa, quería prestar dinero a
cambio de que España, Italia y Grecia recortaran sus gastos para que no necesitaran más préstamos
en el futuro y pudieran devolver lo que debían. En estos países del Sur de Europa, estas
condiciones se vieron como un auténtico asalto a la soberanía nacional ¿Quién se cree
que es Alemania para decirnos cómo debemos gastar nuestro dinero? Mientras tanto, los
alemanes le decían a Merkel “¿Quién nos
manda ayudar a otros países? ¡Esto es la
Unión Europea, no una ONG!”.
Entre esos alemanes estaban este grupo de
economistas; ALEXANDER GAULAND, BERN LUCKE y KONRAD ADAM. Estos fueron los creadores
del partido ALTERNATIVA ELECTORAL 2013, que después se convertiría en ALTERNATIVA POR
ALEMANIA. Muchos de los creadores de este partido venían de trabajar en bancos y universidad
de la parte occidental de Alemania. Ciudades como FRANKFURT, COLONIA o BOHN. Quedaros con
esto porque es MUY importante. En su programa electoral decían que Alemania tenía que
abandonar el euro y volver al marco alemán ¿Por qué? Primero porque así evitaban rescatar
a esas economías pobres del Sur de Europa. Segundo, porque así protegían la economía
alemana de una, más que posible devaluación del euro. Como os decíamos en ESTE otro vídeo,
Alemania debe su riqueza, en buena medida, a haber tenido siempre una moneda fuerte.
Pero tanto Grecia como España, estaban presionando para que el Banco Central Europeo imprimiera
más billetes con los que pagar sus deudas.
Lógicamente, esta idea sonaba bastante mal
para muchos economistas. Y por eso, los primeros votantes de Alternativa
por Alemania tenían muy poco que ver con
esos hooligans de extrema derecha que podemos
imaginar. Eran empresarios, economistas y
profesores universitarios. Eso explica por
qué los medios les llamaban “el partido
de los profesores” y por qué en esas elecciones
federales de 2013, ni siquiera consiguieran
sacar un solo diputado.
Pensadlo bien, la política monetaria no es,
precisamente, el tema más sexy para un programa
electoral. Sólo los suscriptores de VisualPolitik nos preocupamos por estas cosas.
Sin embargo, el destino de ALTERNATIVA POR ALEMANIA cambió en julio del año 2015. Hasta
entonces, el economista BERN LUCKE había sido el presidente del partido. Y la nueva
lideresa, FRAUKE PETRY, tenía unos planes
muy distintos. De entrada, a diferencia de
la antigua cúpula directiva, PETRY venía
de la antigua Alemania del Este. Y traía
una cultura política muy distinta. Para ella,
esos temas de política monetaria, déficit
y responsabilidad fiscal no eran tan importantes. Era consciente de que había un nicho de votantes
insatisfechos que estaban más preocupados por otras cosas como los inmigrantes o la
identidad alemana. Con este tipo de propuestas, además, se ganaba la simpatía de varios
líderes internacionales como el británico
Nigel Farage, del UKIP, la francesa Marine
Le PEN, del Frente Nacional y… ¡Cómo no!
Nuestro gran amigo, la mascota de VisualPolitik,
el hombre que no podía faltar en ninguna
fiesta…
“La lideresa del partido de extrema derecha
alemán se reúne con Putin en Moscú”
Lo sé, se que hablamos mucho de Vladimir
Putin en este canal… ¡Pero es que es imposible
resistirse! Todo esto coincidió con la llegada de miles
de refugiados de Siria, Iraq y Libia. Merkel
les estaba recibiendo con los brazos abiertos.
Y muchos alemanes no estaban contentos.
Así que en las elecciones regionales de 2016,
Alternativa por Alemania se presentó con
un programa totalmente distinto a lo que habían
propuesto sus fundadores. Eso explica por qué muchos de estos economistas
abandonaron el barco. Entre ellos, el mismísimo BERN LUCKE, que fue su primer presidente.
“Este partido ha caído, irremediablemente,
en las manos
equivocadas” –Bern Lucke
Desde entonces, Alternativa por Alemania tiene dos facciones enfrentadas. Por un lado están
los remanentes del núcleo fundador. Pero
cada vez son menos. En su lugar, la mayor
parte de sus miembros han llegado bajo la
batuta de Frauke Petry.
Esto se traduce en muchos más votos. Pero también muchos más quebraderos de cabeza:
“La actual crisis de AFD comenzó a mediados de enero con el discurso rompe tabúes del
radical BJORN HOCKE, que en un bar de Dresden, pidió que Alemania de un giro de 180 grados
a su política de recordar y expiar por su
pasado nazi.”
Por muy partido de extrema derecha que seas, este tipo de cosas no están bien vistas en
Alemania. Y por eso la señora Petry ha tenido más de un problema. Incluso tiene una denuncia
pendiente porque, al parecer, algunas de sus propuestas podrían chocar con la propia legislación
alemana, que intenta prevenir el regreso de
un posible partido nazi. Sin embargo, pese
a las salidas de tono y la división interna,
Alternativa por Alemania ha sido capaz de
dar la sorpresa en estas elecciones. Y la
pregunta es ¿Quiénes les han votado? Ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
LAS DOS ALEMANIAS
En los últimos años, la economía alemana
está on fire. Los sueldos crecen, las empresas
exportan y la desigualdad es casi inexistente. Bueno… esto último es discutible. Sí,
vale, es cierto, que apenas hay pobreza en
las calles y que el tejido productivo se reparte
por todo el país. Pero si miramos la distribución de la renta por regiones, vemos una división
muy clara. Si os fijáis en este mapa, veréis que hay
una parte roja y una parte azul. La parte
azul es la más rica. La parte roja es la
más pobre. La parte azul corresponde a lo
que en su día era Alemania occidental. La
parte roja corresponde a lo que en su día
era la Alemania del este. La Alemania comunista.
Esa Alemania que se pasó al capitalismo en 1989 pero que todavía no ha llegado a disfrutar
del mismo nivel de vida que sus vecinos del Oeste.
Si tenéis la ocasión de visitar una ciudad
como DRESDEN, en el Este de Alemania, veréis
que todavía está llena de grúas y obras.
Casi todos los edificios están construídos
hace muy poco tiempo. Y eso indica una cosa: el proceso de reunificación aún no ha terminado.
Por supuesto, si comparamos el nivel de vida de un alemán oriental con el de un griego
o un español, no parece que les vaya tan mal. Pero los alemanes se comparan con sus conciudadanos.
Y ahí, salen bastante mal parados. “Schwedt no tiene suficientes oportunidades industriales
y no tiene suficientes instalaciones educativas apropiadas. Un centro cultural y deportivo
son todo lo que hay para que la gente disfrute de su ciudad. EL centro de la ciudad está
mortalmente tranquilo. Y muchos jóvenes emigran a las grandes ciudades del Oeste”
Concretamente, en esta ciudad, en la ciudad de SCHWEDT es uno de los lugares donde Alternativa
por Alemania ha sacado más de un 20% de los votos. Y un poco más abajo, en el estado
de BAJA SAJONIA, la extrema derecha ha sido la fuerza más votada.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de economía! Hablamos de una cultura
política totalmente distinta.
Pensadlo bien, los alemanes del este han vivido
generaciones enteras con un sistema político totalmente distinto. Eso significa una educación
distinta, un estilo de vida distinto y unos
valores distintos. En estas regiones, la moderación
no es, precisamente, un valor a tener en cuenta. De hecho, el partido de extrema izquierda,
DIE LINKE, cosecha muchos de sus votos en los barrios de Berlín que estaban en la parte
este del muro. ¡No sólo eso! Mientras los alemanes occidentales
se pasaron décadas recordando su pasado nazi, el gobierno de la República Democrática
de Alemania se dedicó a crear un nuevo sentimiento de orgullo nacional.
Así que, cuando uno de los candidatos de
AFD dice que hay que reconocer la valentía
de los soldados alemanes durante la II Guerra Mundial, en Colonia se echan las manos a la
cabeza mientras que en Leizpig dicen “bueno, pues vale”.
¡Pero sin duda alguna hay una pregunta aún más importante! ¿Por qué en el Este de
Alemania están tan en contra de los inmigrantes y los refugiados? Muchos pensaréis que es
porque están hartos de convivir con tantos
musulmanes que no se quieren integrar.
Pero aquí os voy a dar la cifra que os romperá los esquemas. De los más de 9 millones de
inmigrantes que hay en Alemania, ni siquiera medio millón vive en el este. Como os podéis
imaginar, la mayor parte de los extranjeros
que se marchan a Alemania, eligen las regiones
más ricas. Así que encontrarse a una mujer
cubierta con un HIJAB en las calles de Dresden
es bastante poco común. Es más ¿A que no adivináis cuál es el principal grupo de
inmigrantes que hay en Alemania del Este?
Efectivamente, los rusos. Más de la mitad
de los inmigrantes que viven en esta zona
vienen del país del vodka, la balalaika y
Vladimir Putin. Y, por supuesto, son el mayor nicho de audiencia de Rusia Today en Alemania.
Eso explica cosas como esta.
AFD despliega dos ejes de campaña para atraer a los votantes ruso alemanes
Así que ahora la pregunta es… ¿Créeis
que Alternativa por Alemania puede seguir
cosechando votos en próximas elecciones alemanas o las divisiones internas acabarán con ellos?
¿Qué papel pueden jugar en la próxima legislatura? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis saber por qué
por qué Alemania es la fábrica del mundo,
haced click en este vídeo.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.